they'd been gathering since midweek for
this the resumption of Donald Trump's
election campaign halted in March
because of Corona and now resumed in
spite of it
I've been shaked I don't have it so now
I'm not too concerned about it there's
always going to be that risk in large
populations there is a mixture of
indifference and ignorance to the fact
that in this county alone on this day
alone they've seen their highest number
of cases yet the Kovach grim reaper
among the anti-trump errs wasn't making
much of an impact either to destroy then
a block away in the arena he arrived we
begin our campaign and you just want to
thank all of you you are warriors I've
been watching
I've been watching the fake news for
weeks now and everything is negative
don't go don't come don't do anything
today it was like I've never seen
anything like it I've never seen
anything like it
you are warriors the arena holds 19,000
we're told 10,000 were given access
temperatures were checked but masks not
mandatory when you do testing to that
extent you're gonna find more people
you're gonna find more cases so I said
to my people slow the testing down
please outside the overflow area was
packed up even before he'd finished
speaking the plan was for him to speak
out here to his team claims supporters
didn't come because they were blocked by
protesters we saw no evidence of that
but instead in the side streets around
the arena we found supporters and
opponents debating the merits of the
Trump era there are pockets of debate
conversation all over this area every
now and again it does flare up as the
evening wore on more of those who oppose
everything the president stands for
faced off with his supporters they are
passionate but angry and deeply divided
the unhinge left-wing mob is trying to
vandalize our history desecrate our
monuments our beautiful monument this
cruel campaign of censorship and
exclusion violates everything we hold
dear is America's honestly do you think
that the line back outside more intense
argument this is Adam from Texas angry
because he is insulted that they are
calling him racist we do agree with
America first cuz we've been getting
screwed and trade agreements for twenty
forty years patriotic nationalist race
creed her gender
anything else not matter that there are
five months until the election five more
months of this debate and division Mark
Stone Sky News in Tulsa